a gang war a famous gang war erupted for
about three or four months in 1926 and
it was between the shelves and brothers
and the burger gang about 40 or 50 men
were killed but the Shelton's this was a
vicious gang were brought out and it
included the first aerial bombing the
first and only one in American soil when
the Shelton's commandeered a World War
one Jenny by plane and flew over Charlie
burgers hideout which is like a little
State State Lodge called Shady Rest in
deeps of Illinois and they dropped them
down over shady wrists one created the
only fatalities in American bombing
history because this was the only
airplane raid we've ever had in American
history I wrote the book because first
of all I've had a lifetime interest and
I've been around a lot of years in the
started gangster history of downstate
Illinois I'm a downstate Illinois and I
grew up in Belleville Illinois which is
next East st. Louis and across the
Mississippi River you've got st. Louis
and the NE st. Louis figured heavily in
the gangster history of downstate
Illinois the Shelton's basically the
Shelton gang was run by three brothers
Carl Shelton who was a leader
big Earl Shelton his right-hand man and
the youngest brother in the family
Bernard who was known as Bernie now they
were three of the seven children who
grew to adulthood in a family associated
with old Maul and Paul Sheldon down a
deep Southern Illinois specifically in
Wayne County which is in the deep part
of the state they grew up very poor they
often had a tough time even having food
on the table they lived in a very
ramshackle little house about four miles
east of Fairfield Illinois one thing
though they did learn as kids and
seniors were to shoot guns
and they learn real well and eventually
when Prohibition set in they bought a
Tavern in East st. Louis and soon were
engaging obviously because of
prohibition they were engaging in
bootlegging and started serving other
taverns being the bootlegging the
sources of liquor illegal liquor for all
the other taverns in East st. Louis at
Tamra's niece a law student Lee Clovis
men prohibition and the Shelton's
establish themselves as the major
bootleggers of southern Illinois that
was their first real identity and they
were tough and they remain and they were
violent and they were smart and they
asserted themselves very quickly in the
rapidly emerging world of organized
crime that was that that really was
spawned during Prohibition that's one
thing a prohibition did it did spawn
what is now modern organized crime in
the United States now as far the
Shelton's the three Shelton's that led
the gang the three of the seven kids
there were five boys and two girls and
three of the five boys were leaders of
the Shelton gang the leader was Carl
Shelton who was very handsome very
smooth very soft-spoken he was handsome
he was a ladies man and he was very much
a very charismatic actually his brother
big Earl was very good with mathematics
and figures and business figures even
though none of the boys got out of grade
school but a big girl was was was kind
of lieutenant to his brother Carl and
then the third brother at the head of
the gang was Bernie Bernard known as
Bernie Shelton and he was the most
violent of the three Bernie liked to
shoot first and talk later Bernie was
the enforcer as you know every criminal
organization has one or more enforcers
Bernie was the enforcer the years they
gained prominence and in I say 1920 to
1923 early in the era of prohibition
and they they quickly establish
themselves as the go-to guys in the
bootlegging business for all of southern
Illinois they had a lot of lieutenants
and so on some of whom had their own
little Empires within the bigger Empire
and that's not unusual and it had
everything going their way until there
were a lot of people obviously
prohibition passed because there were
people who wanted an enforced right and
it wasn't being enforced in most parts
of downstate Illinois
city officials looked the other way
police chiefs looked the other way
sheriffs looked the other way so that
gave rise to a resurgence of the Ku Klux
Klan in southern Illinois now that Klan
was basically said it was like a
vigilante organization it wasn't like
the comic book story Klan of later years
of 50s or 60s and so on years in which
half the members of a local Klan or FBI
agent but the Klan was very serious for
about two years two or three year period
and it was comprised of a lot of leading
citizens really now they were the white
robes they were the pointed pointed head
coverings or whatever but there were a
lot of leading citizens and in the Klan
because they wanted provision force and
when the regular law enforcement
authorities were not prohibiting or not
enforcing prohibition it took it upon
themselves in a vigilante sort of way to
do it and it resulted in incredible
violence and in murders and in
disastrous situations and it led to an
all-out war in so don't know between the
Klan and between the bootleggers the
bootleggers led by Carl Shelton it was
like a bootlegging army and incredible
encounters occurred that III detail of
course in great detail in my book
brothers notorious but the the things
that occurred as a clan and the
bootleggers fought it out made
front-page headlines across the United
States from the New York Times to the
Los Angeles
and eventually the clan the bootleggers
defeat of the clan the clan went back in
the woodwork okay but then dissension
erupted in the ranks of the Shelton
Empire and one gangster particularly
Charlie Berger who had his own little
Empire in South Eastern Illinois within
the bigger Shelton Empire a gang war a
famous gang war erupted for about three
or four months in 1926 again it made
headlines across the country and it was
between the Shelton brothers and the
Berger gang by 40 or 50 men were killed
the Shelton's reassure peak in 1930 they
had the world their world by the tail in
1930 everything had had had worked at
that point finally come on to their
benefit their territory started the
south of Peoria a little bit south of
Peoria and went all the way down to the
tip of the state at Carol Illinois
downward the Mississippi meets the Ohio
their influence and operations went a
little bit in the southern Indiana and a
little bit in the southern Missouri also
as well as a little bit of Western
Kentucky they their headquarters
basically were in East st. Louis which
is st. Clair County in Illinois and in
the st. Croix Madison County area
they're always linked together across
the river from st. Louis that was the
foundation for for many years of the
Shelton's criminal enterprises
bootlegging then labor racketeering then
eventually control of all the illegal
gambling peoria comes into play in the
Shelton's story it's the last big hurrah
in the shelton saga world war ii is
starting and it was interesting that
peoria was wide open everything and
anything went in peoria it had a
national reputation for being a
wide-open city and amazingly the
underworld activity in peoria had
continued to be dominated and led by
local gangsters
now this wasn't the case anywhere else
in Illinois Northup you it was all
dominated by the Al Capone syndicate out
of Chicago
and starting south of Peoria to the tip
of the state it was all Shelton gang
territory and Peoria had remained kind
of a neutral buffer zone between these
two major criminal entities and Peoria
was a haven of shady activities back
then but control those activities had
remained in the hands of local gangsters
well as World War 2 is getting underway
the shell tonight excuse me
the component router Chicago made a long
anticipated move to come into Peoria and
just take over Peoria because it was it
was booming in terms of things the
gangsters wanted to do to make dough and
the local gangsters in Peoria calculated
decision they knew they could not resist
the component Capone hides but what they
did is that they're going to be under
the wing of a major criminal element
they decided the Shelton's were
preferable and so the Shelton boys
brothers were invited to come to Peoria
expand their empire a little bit north
go right into Peoria and provide
protection for the criminal network in
Peoria from the Capone eyes and that's
what happened
the Shelton were invited in they came in
to provide protection now it didn't take
very long it was predictable they not
only provided protection for the rackets
in Peoria but they took over and during
world war ii the Shelton's were very
powerful in Peoria now only two of the
three brothers moved to Peoria Carl and
Bernie big Earl although he was involved
in Peoria big Earl never moved to to to
pure he remained down in there
strongholds now in southern Illinois but
during World War two
the statewide Shelton criminal network
was run out of Peoria and it was in
Peoria that Karl Karl consider himself a
businessman not a gangster he considered
himself supplying needs and ones of the
public the public wanted to drink he
supplied the liquor and the beer you
know the public one of the gamble was
illegal in Illinois but they wanted to
gamble Karl provided casinos and small
gambling parlors and so on he consider
himself a businessman he considered
himself a full manner of economic
activity economic prosperity they
weren't Dexter's in Carl's eyes but
anyway in Peoria they quickly establish
some of some of themselves as the bosses
and and Carl was literally along with
the legendary mayor Woodruff at the time
they were running Peoria during World
War two and and and and they got along
very well very well
mayor Woodruff tolerated vice as long as
it provided revenue for the city coffers
enter a number citizen and as long as
violence was kept under control and the
Shelton's were very adept at meeting
those requirements they've certainly
paid a share of all the illegal stuff to
the to to the city and they kept
violence
under under control there was very
little of it until near the end when the
Shelton's were sort of you know getting
a little fat and and and looking to
maybe at least Karl the leader was
looking to sort of retire and go back
and so no no where is going to live like
a country squire with all of his land
and Holdings and he was big in the oil
industry but the Shelton's really Peoria
was as if there were politicians you
would say that
Peoria was the last hurrah of the
Shelton's the death of Carl Shelton was
one of the three big stories of the year
in 1947 in Illinois the other two big
stories were the Centralia on my mind
disaster which took over a hundred lives
and in Jackie Robinson Jackie Robinson
breaking the color barrier in Major
League Baseball was in 1947 when the
Brooklyn Dodgers brought up Jackie
Robinson that was a very big deal and
and that was one of the three big
stories of the year in in downstate
Illinois Jackie Robinson coming to the
major leagues
this'n trillium i disaster and the
murder of Carl Sheldon
it happened in 1947 on a beautiful
October morning Carl was down in
southern Illinois riding an open-air
Jeep on his on a country lane near a lot
of the farmland he owned and had bought
with his ill-gotten gains and he was
assassinated there four or five gunmen
waiting in brush near a bridge and he
was machine gun to death there there
were two bodyguards and a truck
following him but they were they didn't
function and Carl Carl was a murder on
the spot you hit by fourteen fifteen
sixteen bullets a machine gunning and
and that and and that of course was
that that was the beginning of the end
of the show because curl was the brains
he was the only one who knew all the
pieces of the puzzle
he was the only one who knew who was
getting paid off where and that after
that it was difficult to keep the
Sheldon gang together
Bernie tried and Bernie was a course up
here and Bernie tried to continue
running things Bernie had a tavern rat
in Farmington Road right right a little
bit down the hill from the edge of
Peoria just right outside the purest
city line and a year later though Bernie
himself was assassinated shot on the
parking lot of his tavern and died about
a half-hour later at a hospital in
Peoria big girl survived three or four
assassination attempts he was hit but he
survived he eventually got the message
and the Shelton Empire disintegrated
anyway and he went to Florida we lived
the last half of his life he engaged
there in legitimate business enterprises
he became a wealthy man in in Florida in
the Jacksonville Florida area involved
in a lot of developments the thing they
said about big Earl was a big girl
flipped a half-dollar in the air it
floated down as a five dollar bill and
big girl lived to be he lived in from
1986 when he died of natural causes at
the age of 96 and Illinois had a
terrific era weather many people like it
or not of lawlessness and it captured
the front page headlines and the
imagination of readers and people
throughout the country and I think if
you're going to study the history of
this state and you want to be serious
about it you cannot ignore the role of
gangs like the Shelton's and so on and
what they represented